géographique la russie ne peut pas
complètement se protéger de cette
épidémie puisque des pays qui sont
voisins de la russie sont déjà largement
touchés et on ne peut pas complètement
objectivement bloquer tout accès à 7 et
à notre pays nous faisons le maximum de
façon organisée de façon professionnelle
et par anticipation et la priorité c'est
la vie et la santé de nos citoyens et au
moment de déployer une autre secteur
santé toutes nos ressources sont
impliqués et je m'adresse en particulier
aux médecins et aux infirmiers ou
infirmières à tout le personnel soignant
ou de tous les établissements de santé à
nos scientifiques
vous êtes là sur la ligne de front
je vous remercie cordialement tous pour
le travail que vous faites et je prie de
la population d'être particulièrement
attentive à ce que font les médecins
actuellement beaucoup va dépendre de
cela et en particulier cela concerne les
groupes les plus vulnérables de la
population
le troisième âge et tous ceux qui sont
sensibles à des maladies chroniques
pour eux comme pour l'ensemble des
citoyens
l'objectif prioritaire c'est de réduire
au maximum les risques bien entendu se
pose la question de l'organisation du
référendum sur les amendements à la
constitution avec la date initialement
prévue du 22 avril vous savez que à quel
point je suis attentif à cette question
et bien entendu je vais vous demander de
donner votre avis sur ce point qui est
important pour l'avenir de notre pays
pour
l'ensemble de notre société mais comme
je les dis déjà la priorité absolue pour
nous c'est la santé la vie et la
sécurité de la population
pour cette raison il me semble important
de reporter ce scrutin à plus tard
nous allons évaluer l'évolution de la
situation sur son plan et sur la base de
l'avis des scientifiques des médecins et
spécialistes
nous prendrons une décision sur le
report de cette date de ce scrutin
ensuite il est important ici de faire
tout pour limiter une propagation rapide
de l'épidémie et par conséquent je
déclare la semaine qui vient comme une
semaine de congé avec maintien des
salaires c'est à dire qu'à partir du
samedi 28 mars jusqu'au dimanche 5 avril
l'ensemble des structures vont être en
congés qu'il s'agisse des services de
santé des transports des banques et des
services de l'état
ces secteurs-là maintiendront leurs
activités normales
mais cette semaine de congé a pour
objectif justement de limiter une
propagation de l'épidémie et je
m'adresse à tous les citoyens du pays
je vous propose d'agir de façon
raisonnée et pas de façon négligente
on peut se dire cela me concerne non ça
concerne chacun d'entre nous et ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui dans beaucoup de
pays occidentaux
que ce soit en europe ou de l'autre côté
de l'océan peut nous arriver dans un
avenir très proche toutes les
recommandations doivent être suivies il
faut se préserver soi même et ses
proches
faire preuve de discipline et de
responsabilité
et croyez moi le plus sûr aujourd'hui
c'est de rester à la maison
je m'appuie aussi je m'intéresse aussi
aux questions économiques
là aussi il faut que nous prenions des
mesures supplémentaires tout d'abord
pour assurer la garantie sociale des de
la population maintenir les salaires est
également un soutien apporté aux pme qui
occupent des millions de personnes par
sept par conséquent des mesures
prioritaires vont être prises première
toutes les allocations sociales qui
doivent être payés aux citoyens dans les
six prochains mois doit être poursuivie
automatiquement sans qu'il soit
nécessaire de préserver de présenter
pardon des documents spécifiques par
exemple c'est une famille à des avantage
sur les charges locatives
elle n'a pas besoin de présenter des
fiches de salaire pour continuer à
bénéficier de cet avantage
par exemple tous ceux qui font l'objet
des célébrités des célébrations du 75e
anniversaire de la victoire de la
deuxième guerre mondiale doivent
continuer à bénéficier des avantages qui
ont été destinés jusqu'au mois de mai et
je propose que dans les trois mois à
venir
à partir du mois d'avril toutes les
familles ayant le droit au capital
maternelle de recevoir 5000 roubles
supplémentaires par enfant par famille
pendant trois mois 7
ce soutien financier est important
notamment pour les familles dont les
enfants ne peuvent pas aller aujourd'hui
à l'école ou au jardin d'enfants parce
que les enfants sont peut-être en congé
maladie par exemple et ensuite concerne
les allocations pour les enfants de 3 à
7 anges
demande au gouvernement de renforcer les
mesures pour que toutes les familles
recevront ressources puissent recevoir
les allocations prévues pour l'été
non pas en juillet comme d'habitude mais
plutôt de même que je demande au
gouverneur de d'informer les services
fiscaux et d'état civil au niveau de
leur entité celui ci est important je
vous prie chers citoyens d'être attentif
à cela troisième point il faut soutenir
ceux qui sont aujourd'hui en congé
maladie ou qui ont perdu leur travail
donc un maintien de l'expérience
professionnelle et du clr cela concerne
en priorité les jeunes notamment ceux
qui en raison d'un congé maladie
reçoivent un salaire très très bas donc
je prie d'instaurer une norme minimale
qui doit être au moins minimum au
salaire minimum officielle en russie
ensuite en fonction de la situation nous
prendrons d'autres mesures
complémentaires l'économie de la russie
comme celle d'autres pays en raison de
l'épidémie peut subir des dommages très
grave
et comme je lé dé il s'agit de soutenir
ceux qui peuvent être confrontés au
risque de perdre leur travail
à part quelques catégories de citoyens
aujourd'hui le montant maximum de
l'allocation chômage est aujourd'hui de
huit mille roubles par mois et je
propose d'augmenter ce montant jusqu au
salaire minimum c'est-à-dire de douze
mille roubles quatrième point il ya une
zone de risque ce sont les crédits des
sétois bien entendu en période de
réduction des revenus
il est beaucoup plus difficile voire
impossible de payer les mensualités
donc je propose d'introduire des
vacances deux crédits de quoi il s'agit
c'est sage et que c'est par exemple une
personne se trouve dans une situation
difficile en raison d'une réduction
supérieure à 30% il ya deux sont revenus
c'est à dire que le service de la date
de la dette peut être interrompu pendant
une période sans aucune pénalité
je demande à la banque de russie de
mettre en place un système de
prolongement des crédits et notamment de
soutien aux auto entrepreneurs
et donc si effectivement les raisons
objectives sont principalement tels que
la personne se trouve dans un cul-de-sac
il faut que cette procédure doit être
adoptée adapté de façon à ce qu'il n'y
ait pas eu de charges supplémentaires
pour les sites et je demande au
gouvernement de prendre les mesures
nécessaires cinquième point les pme
notamment dans le secteur des services
sont aujourd'hui confrontés à une forte
baisse des commandes et une réduction
d'activité et donc il faut aider ces
entreprises à poursuivre leur activité
même réduite mais en conservant
l'ensemble de leur effectif
encore une fois c'est mon appel à tous
les employeurs de russie c'est assurer
la stabilité du marché du travail et
éviter une brusque augmentation du
chômage et le gouvernement apportera son
soutien à toutes les entreprises dans
toutes les danses toutes les branches
qui se trouvent dans cette situation
difficile de maintenir mettre en place
les mesures proches suivante c'est à
dire que les pme doivent bénéficier de
reports de paiement
d'impôt pour les prochains mois et pour
les microentreprises
en plus de ce report bénéficiez en plus
d'un report sur les cotisations sociales
en ce qui concerne les services
bancaires les pme et les micro
entreprises sont aujourd'hui dans une
situation difficile doivent aussi permis
b énéfice y ait d'un report de paiement
des crédits sur une période de six mois
et je demande à la banque centrale et au
gouvernement de prendre des mesures
complémentaires supplémentaires
favorable en faveur de la stabilité du
marché des crédits à l'aide des
garanties d'état et des subventions
dédiées par ailleurs les entreprises qui
se trouvent dans une situation difficile
doivent être protégées du risque de
faillite avec l'établissement d'un
moratoire sur les déclarations de
faillite pour bloquer le système des
dettes
je le répète ces entreprises ces mesures
seront diffusées à toutes les
entreprises dans tous les secteurs
touchés par ailleurs je demande au
gouvernement d'effectuer un suivi
détaillé de ces mesures de leurs
applications et des adaptations qu'il
faudra y faire en fonction de la
situation sixième point
aujourd'hui nous devons faire le maximum
pour maintenir le revenu des citoyens et
notamment de la population employée dans
les pme donc pour que ces entreprises
bénéficient de ressources
supplémentaires
je propose de réduire de 30 % à 15 %
leurs cotisations secure ii
d'assurance pour que le les salaires
puissent être supérieurs au salaire
minium et pour les salaires qui sont au
même niveau voire en dessous pour que
les cotisations sociales soit au
contraire maintenu à 30 % 7
ces mesures sont pas seulement pour
quelques mois pas seulement pour réagir
à cette crise mais elles sont prises à
long terme de façon à provoquer à
proposer des stimulations pour le
développement des entreprises et enfin
je propose encore deux autres mesures
gens parlent de façon distincte première
chose
les paiements de revues que ce soit
notamment des revenus offshore ou venant
de l'étranger
ils doivent être imposées de façon juste
dans la mesure où il ya différents
schémas de ce qu'on appelle les
optimisations souvent ils n'ont que 2 %
de d'imposition alors que les citoyens
ordinaires avec un revenu ordinaire paye
13% donc on a là une injustice et je
propose donc pour ceux qui ne font
évacuer leur argent à des sur des
comptes étrangers d'avoir maintenant une
imposition de 15% et cela nécessitera
des corrections dans les dispositions
réglementaires fiscales et je demande au
gouvernement de prendre les mesures et
si nos partenaires étrangers n'adopte
pas de n'adopter pas ces mesures sur la
base des accords signés
la russie les prendra de façon
unilatérale et de façon à proposer à
promouvoir nos ressources nationales
dans beaucoup de pays c'est le dernier
point on voit que les investissements en
titres sont à l'étranger sont soumis à
une imposition que la sicor en russie ce
n'est pas le cas donc je propose ici que
sur les titres boursiers et d'établir
une imposition de 13% à partir d'un
million c'est à dire pas
l'investissement lui même mais les
revenus les dividendes qui en découlent
et je souligne encore cette mesure ne
concernera qu environ 1% des
investisseurs cela et pour que cette
mesure de rendre notre pays un des plus
attractifs au monde sur ce plan et je
vous prie d'être compréhensifs à l'égard
de ces mesures et je pense que toutes
les entrées supplémentaires au budget de
l'état
à la suite de ces deux mesures doivent
être réorientés directement au soutien
des familles avec des enfants et des
familles est en priver de leurs revenus
ou étant en congé maladie
chers citoyens toutes les mesures que je
viens d'énumérer et qui sont prises ou
qui vont être prises fonctionneront
elles donneront un résultat si nous
faisons preuve de
cohésion si nous comprenons bien la
difficulté de la situation actuelle et
si la l'état la société les citoyens
agissent de concert et si nous faisons
tout ce qui dépend de chacun d'entre
nous nous devons penser réfléchir à
notre responsabilité personnelle à
l'égard de ceux qui vivent avec nous de
ceux qui nous sont proches et si on
regarde bien
cette solidarité c'est la clé de la
société c'est la clé de sa vie et notre
responsabilité face à ce défi est
importante
je vous remercie pour votre attention